im Grunde genau zum Thema Robert Habeck
ist da und meine Kollegin Katharina kühn
kommentiert das für sie heute in seiner
Anhörung im Wirtschaftsausschuss und am
Plenum hat nun schon hier seine Rede
begonnen Mario Czaja für die
Unionsfraktion er hatte die Gelegenheit
deutlich zu machen dass es sich um einen
beamtenrechtliches Dienst Vergehen
seines Staatssekretärs gehandelt hat
dass ein Disziplinarverfahren nach sich
ziehen muss
er hätte
alle Karten auf den Tisch legen können
volle Transparenz schaffen können und er
hätte sagen müssen dass hier ist heute
die Abschiedsvorstellung meines
Staatssekretärs ich versetze Herrn
reichen in den Ruhestand das wäre die
richtige Entscheidung heute gewesen
aber so müssen wir leider erneut über
habex grüne familienklicke reden ein
Betrieb bei dem immer mehr Filz und
Verstrickungen ans Tageslicht kommt er
Habeck glaubt nämlich dass es sich bei
Herrn reichen nicht bloß um ein
Staatssekretär handelt der alles kann
sondern der Habeck glaubt es hält sich
um einen verbeamteten Superman den er
dort in seine Ministerium hat und jetzt
schauen wir uns einmal die Realität an
gasumlage
angekündigt Ergebnis ein riesen Mucks
KfW-Förderung für das Effizienzhaus 55
beendet Ergebnis Baugenehmigung in
Deutschland eingebrochen immer weniger
können sich den Hausbau leisten und
jetzt schlägt der heizungshammer in
unserem Land mit voller Wucht zu Angst
und Schrecken verbreitet dieser Minister
im ganzen Land was da im Grünen
superministerium läuft das kann man auf
eine Formel bringen Superminister plus
Superman gleich super Chaos
[Applaus]
manch ein Super Mario ist auch ein Super
Mario da haben sie völlig recht danke
schön für diesen kurzen Hinweis
sie müssen die Schreiben der Menschen in
unserem Land doch auch bekommen da
schreibt uns einer dieser Tage wir haben
Angst unser Heim zu verlieren und die
Vorgaben in Sachen Heizung nicht
finanzieren zu können
ein zweiter Brief von einem Rentner eine
kleine Rente er schreibt voller Angst
mir wird der Umbau das Genick brechen
oder ein Fleischermeister bei dem ich
jüngst im Südharz gewesen bin der
erzählte mir in vierter Generation sein
Betrieb die Energiekosten haben sich
verzehnfacht trotz Deckung seit
Jahresanfang schreibt der rote Zahlen er
weiß nicht mehr weiter jede Entscheidung
die dieser Wirtschaftsminister auf den
Weg gebracht hat hat es dem Mittelstand
in Deutschland noch schwerer gemacht
viele haben Existenz Angst sie haben
Angst dass die nächste Entscheidung aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium das
endgültige Aus für Ihren Betrieb
bedeutet Liebe Ampel sie müssen diese
Briefe doch auch bekommen das kann doch
nicht sein dass sie das auch nicht lesen
das muss diesen Mann doch interessieren
was er da macht
aber
was ist was ist da alles wieder falsch
gelaufen jeder vernünftige Mensch weiß
doch dass er zunächst mal prüfen muss
was ist denn technisch überhaupt
verfügbar dann würde er die Finanzierung
prüfen und dann geht er in die Umsetzung
ganz am Ende gibt es dann ein Datum wann
er loslegt und ich bin mir sicher es gab
in seinem Ministerium genügend
vernünftige Leute die genau das getan
haben aber er Habeck untergreichen
machen es umgedreht sie planen es nicht
zu hören den nicht zu die klicke hat
sich abgeschottet es wird überhaupt gar
nicht mehr mit den Fachleuten geredet um
es mal in ein anderes Bild zu packen auf
eine Wärmepumpe wartest du 18 Monate ob
du einen Handwerker findest weißt du
nicht und wie du es bezahlen sollst
weißt du auch nicht die Bedenken werden
aber nicht gehört Sorgen sind egal es
ist die Reise in das grüne absurde des
Herrn die wir da erleben
bei einer ich ich verstehe ihre Unruhe
sehr gut ich verstehe ihre Unruhe sehr
gut Herr Möllemann und andere wissen
ganz genau die wären längst
zurückgetreten schon wegen einer
Kleinigkeit hier wird ein Skandal nach
dem anderen deutlich
zum heizungsgesetz hat der Minister
externe fachleuteumstellungnahmen
gebeten acht Tage hatten sie Zeit vier
Tage davon Osterferien dafür gab bei
Ihnen eine Frist wie gesagt von acht
Tagen mehr kann man den Fachleuten nicht
sagen dass man auf ihre Meinung pfeift
dass ihre Auffassung beim legal ist aber
trotzdem 800 Seiten kamen zurück Kritik
Hinweise Anregungen aus den Ländern von
88 Verbänden die sich darüber gedacht
Gedanken gemacht haben da warnt der
Sozialverband das aufbringende
Investitionsmittel überfordert viele
Menschen finanziell da sagen da sagt der
Mieterbund ihr müsst das sozial abfedern
aber diese grüne Clique pfeift darauf
die macht das oft gar keinen Fall wir
brauchen einen Klimaschutz ohne Kosten
Schock und das ist das was wir mit der
Narbe bekommen
ich komme zum Schluss Herr harberg sie
sind Gefangener ihrer Getreuen und ihrer
eigenen Ideologie sie wollen nicht hören
und sehen was draußen los ist sie
organisieren und finanzieren dieses
Netzwerk sie sind der Kopf dieses
Netzwerkes und spätestens seit dieser
Woche spätestens seit dieser Woche ist
die Affäre greifen einer Affäre habe und
weil sie die Sorgen der Menschen nicht
ernst nehmen werden wir ihn ab morgen
eine Stimme geben sie können sich warm
anziehen für ihre soziale Kälte sie sind
über dieses Land bringen das ist kein
Klimaschutz das ist soziale Kälte und
wir werden deutlich machen dass das in
diesem Land nicht funktioniert
[Applaus]
die Aktuelle Stunde
eröffnet und Robert Habeck wohnt dieser
aktuellen Stunde bei auch das ist nicht
selbstverständlich wenn es hier um ein
Ministerium geht in einer aktuellen
Stunde dass der Minister dann
tatsächlich kommt er steht nämlich nicht
auf der Rednerliste hört sich hier aber
an dass die Abgeordneten hier zu sagen
haben
gelten für alle Rednerinnen und Redner
exakt 5 Minuten Redezeit und die
Ankündigung des Endes der Rede ersetzt
nicht den Schlusspunkt
der nächste Redner ist der Kunde meine
Erwähnung von Bundestags viel zu
Präsidenten Petra Paul nächste Redner
ist nun Sebastian Roloff für die
SPD-Fraktion liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich erinnere mich ja eigentlich
gerne noch an die Zeiten zurück als
cdu/csu seriöse Parteien waren wir haben
riesen Probleme in dem Land und wir
gehen diese auch als Ampel an und ich
werde es auch gleich detailliert noch
sagen und sie haben nichts besseres zu
tun als hier in der Aktuellen Stunde mit
Dreck zu werfen in der Hoffnung dass
irgendwie was hängen bleibt und haben
keine Substanz sondern nur
Unterstellungen
die Strategie hat auch oft genug
funktioniert in der Bundesrepublik das
stimmt natürlich aber das macht es nicht
seriöser und wenn wir uns angucken worum
geht es in ihrem Antrag es geht darum
den Vertrauensverlust in dem Klimaschutz
zu verhindern weil es familiäre
Verflechtungen in der Personalpolitik
des Bundeswirtschaftsministers gäbe das
scheint mir die nächste Unwahrheit zu
sein es geht ihnen eher darum diejenigen
Misskredit zu bringen die die
Energiewende in diesem Land vorantreiben
und das ist natürlich normal dass man
darüber Konzepte streitet und da können
sie auch Vorschläge machen und wir sind
hier immer gerne bereit in jede Debatte
zu gehen aber dass sie billiges
politisches Kapital schlagen auch nur
mit Unterstellungen mit Halbwahrheiten
und natürlich zusammen mit der
interessierten Presse ist unter ihrem
Niveau und es wäre mir wirklich peinlich
wenn ich sie wäre und das heute hier
vertreten müsste
worum geht's
ja Staatssekretär reichen hat einen
Fehler gemacht indem er seine
persönliche Befangenheit die man in der
Trauzeugen Eigenschaft sehen kann zu
spät kommuniziert hat weder an der
fachlichen Eignung von Herrn reichen
noch an der von Herrn Schäfer bestehen
irgendwelche Mängel das Verfahren war
korrekt es gegen ist gegen kein Gesetz
verstoßen worden es ist allerdings so
dass es ein Compliance weil dahingehend
gab als das die Trauzeugen Eigenschaft
die kein Verwandtschaftsverhältnis ist
man muss keinen Trauzeugen benennen man
kann 30 Trauzeugen benennen es ist
rechtlich nicht verbindlich es gab aber
die Compliance Empfehlung da
entsprechend abzuhelfen und als das
bekannt wurde wurde das gemacht das
Verfahren wurde neu aufgeräumt und die
Präsidentschaft wird neu vergeben das
Thema ist geklärt die richtigen Schlüsse
wurden rausgezogen und es ist erledigt
sie können wochenlang Kampagne machen
wenn sie wollen mehr Substanz wird aber
nicht und das ist der wesentliche Punkt
heute
stiften Sie ruhig weiter Chaos
diskreditieren sie das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium was
jahrzehntelang von ihrem Haus von
Menschen ihrer Farbe geführt wurde jetzt
ist es auf einmal grüner
Selbstbedienungsladen wirklich
bemerkenswert insbesondere weil viele
Personalentscheidungen auch der
mittleren Ebene und auch viele
Beauftragungen noch von Herrn Altmaier
stammen davon distanzieren sie sich ja
auch immer gerne wenn es ein bisschen
seriöser ginge und vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger Chaos Werder Debatte
glaube ich wirklich geholfen aber
jenseits dessen diskutieren wir das
gerne mit ihnen lassen uns von diesem
scheinen Debatten aber nicht von der
Arbeit abhalten wir werden weiter dafür
sorgen dass die Energieversorgung
erstens gesichert wird und zweitens
klimaaneutral ist und selbstverständlich
legen wir als SPD-Fraktion besonderen
Fokus auf die Bezahlbarkeit da machen
wir weiter und das haben wir auch die
letzten anderthalb Jahre gemacht
die Jahre in der Opposition scheinen
ihnen nicht gut zu tun muss ich noch mal
ganz deutlich sagen dass sie eine dass
sie mit einem selben Thema nun ein
bisschen poetischer formuliert wie die
AFD in der letzten Sitzungswoche hier
Stimmung machen anstatt Konzepte zu
machen und wir dieselben Diskussion noch
mal führen müssen ohne dass es neue
Erkenntnisse gibt im Gegenteil es gibt
mehr Aufklärung sagt alles dass sie
wehrlos und konzeptlos sind und keine
konkreten Themen offensichtlich haben
sondern ist hier nur darum geht Stimmung
zu machen und Menschen durch den Dreck
zu ziehen ich muss es so deutlich sagen
und wenn man so will kann das ja auch
dahingehend sinnvoll sein als das ihre
Skandale Wikipedia Seiten voll füllen
mit dem was sie an Korruptionsfällen in
der Politik allein in den letzten 20
Jahren zu verantworten haben ich kann
schon verstehen dass man da gegensteuern
möchte aber es hat nichts damit zu tun
die Situation der Menschen im Land zu
verbessern und den der Situation und dem
multiblen Krisen den massiven
Transformation Herausforderungen werden
wir uns weiter stellen ob sie mitmachen
oder nicht ihre Anträge diskutieren wir
hierher gelegentlich da kann man auch
immer diskutieren ob die hilfreich sind
aber sowas wie heute bringt uns nicht
weiter das spüren die Menschen im
übrigen auch die Menschen spüren wer
sich ihren Sorgen annimmt Antworten auf
die Zukunft hat und wer billige
politische Punkte machen möchte
herzlichen Dank
soweit Sebastian auch hier für die
SPD-Fraktion Kino hat nun das Wort er
ist Fraktionsvorsitzender aber eine auch
Parteivorsitzender der AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute Robert Habeck hat das
Wirtschaftsministerium zum Vettern
Wirtschaftsministerium gemacht
Staatssekretäre sind mit Experten
verheiratet verschwestert oder
verschwägert ein ganzer Familienclan der
Ehegatte will dem Trauzeugen einen Job
verschaffen und so weiter und so weiter
dieses Geschacher passiert am Bundestag
vorbei und hat mit dem beamtenethos dass
unser Land auszeichnet nichts aber auch
gar nichts zu tun es ist maßlos ist
zerstört Vertrauen in die Politik und
passt zur grünen Agenda der
Transformation an der Arbeit sie haben
ja heute im Ausschuss von company 1
geredet aber von Epos haben Sie
wahrscheinlich noch nie etwas gehört um
Werte Vertrauen Glaubwürdigkeit und das
geht in der Politik und das haben sie
maßlos beschädigt die Union will nun
Konsequenzen aus den familiären
Verpflichtungen ziehen die möchte einen
Untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen das
werden wir genauso fordern also von
daher werden wir wenn die Union vor uns
sein sollte diese Forderung natürlich
unterstützten nur darf dieser Ausschuss
nicht nur die familiärenverflechtungen
des gleichen Plans aufdecken es geht
nämlich um die zentrale Frage wird die
Energiewende die unseren Wohlstand
zerstört von fremden Macht und
Kapitalinteressen gestört gesteuert und
genau das ist das Pudels Kern genau das
legen nämlich die Enthüllung der letzten
Wochen nahe führen die Grünen den
Ausverkauf unseres Landes im fremden
Interesse aus und sie haben hier in
ihrem Vorreden auch die CDU nur eine
Oberfläche gekratzt meine Kollegin
Beatrix von Storch hat die Grünen an
dieser Stelle als den politischen Arm
dieser globalen Finanzinteressen
bezeichnet und damit hat sie den Finger
in die Wunde gelegt und das war bitter
nötig denn die Grünen werfen unser Land
ganz offensichtlich Oligarchen zum Fraß
vor da wäre zum Beispiel
da wäre zum Beispiel die US-Investor
hell Harvey von der Zeit als der
mächtigste grüne der Welt genannt er
finanziert grüne Institute und
Stiftungen hat die Agora Energiewende
mit gegründet dort war Patrick reichen
cheffler ist bevor Robert Habig ihn zum
Staatssekretär ernannt hat agora hat das
Gas und ölheizungsverboten übrigens
schon 2021 gefordert der Autor der
Studie Christian Maas und deswegen
geht's hier noch um ganz andere Personen
Christian Maas ist mittlerweile auch
Staatssekretär bei Harbeck agora Energie
hat schon letztes Jahr den Durchbruch
für die Wärmepumpe angekündigt da muss
man ja fragen ist das Hellseherei oder
ist das Manipulation die Leidtragenden
dieses lobbyums sind die einfachen
deutschen Bürger Mittelständler
Handwerker Industrie sie müssen Böden
herausreisen und Heizung austauschen
jeder zweite Haushalt wird derzeit mit
Erdgas beheizt jeder Vierte
mit Öl für eine Wärmepumpe müssen die
Bürger bis zu 25000 € für Luft und bis
zu 40.000 € für Erdwärme bezahlen dazu
10000 € für Fußbodenheizung 75
Milliarden Euro in Gänze Dächer und auch
Fassaden müssen gedämmt werden das weiß
jeder Handwerker ganz eindeutig ich sage
Ihnen wohin das führt für aber tausende
direkt in die Altersarmut dafür sollen
sie mit ihren Namen weg und vergessen
wir nicht
und vergessen wir nicht die grüne
Energiewende hängt mit den
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland eng
zusammen nämlich schon 2016 kündigte
Harbeck an er werde die Gasimporte aus
Russland stoppen weil wir ein
energiewendeland sind wer also der
Ukraine Krieg nur der Anlass aber nicht
Grund für das Ende von nordstream ein
weiterer Oligarch Larry Fink
Lehrerin darf mit Blackrock den
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine koordinieren je
mehr kaputt ist desto höher die
Investitionen und mit Friedrich Merz
sitzt ja ein Oppositionsführer in diesem
Haus der als top-lobby ist jahrelang für
Blackrock tätig gewesen ist und die
Frage die CDU liegen sie nicht im Bett
mit denselben Investoren wie die grüne
soll ja auch eher nächster
Koalitionspartner sein denn seit Januar
arbeitet Helga Bartsch als Leiterin der
Grundsatzabteilung in havix Ministerium
sie ist so etwas wie das Gehirn des bmwk
sofort war vorbei forschungsleiterin bei
Blackrock in London auch diesen Fäden im
Netzwerk muss der Untersuchungsausschuss
nachgehen koordiniert das Ministerium
hier mich selbst den Ausverkauf unserer
Volkswirtschaft und dann noch eine
Kritik auch an die deutschen Medien
genau das was meine geschätzte Kollegin
alles weil auch gestern schon gesagt hat
das wäre Aufgabe der deutschen und
Medien diesen ganzen Sumpf zu
recherchieren diesen trocken zu legen
diesen ganzen Sumpf nachzugehen das wäre
Aufgabe der Medien gewesen und nicht die
Opposition zu bekämpfen
die Heizung Sparte des deutschen
familienunternehmers Viessmann ist mit
12 Milliarden Euro an den US-Konzernen
global verkauft worden die USA
profitieren vom Wärmepumpen zwang den
us-finanzierten Lobbyisten vorgedacht
haben genau diese Politik die nicht im
Interesse der Bürger das heizungsverbot
muss deshalb zurückgenommen werden und
auch habe ich auch sie müssen
ausgetauscht werden es wäre günstiger
sie auszutauschen als Millionen
Heizungen in Deutschland
und deshalb letzter Satz frau
Präsidentin deshalb müssen diese
ungeheuerlichen Zustände aufgeklärt
werden dann wird sich nämlich wirklich
zeigen der wirklich von der
Industrialisierung Deutschlands
profitiert vielen Dank
vermutet fremde Macht und
Kapitalinteressen und fordert hier die
Aufklärung auch dieser für Bündnis 90
die Grünen im Deutschen Bundestag also
der Partei der auch das Ministerium hier
die das Ministerium innerhalb spricht
nun Andreas stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
danke für diese Rede diese Rede hätte
nicht entlarvender sein können sie haben
nicht ein Wort zur Sache gesagt nicht
ein Wort das was ich hier gemacht haben
sind ihre fossilen Blütenträume wieder
in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen das was
sie gemacht haben ist gegen Klimaschutz
zu agitieren so wie sie es 16 Jahre lang
gemacht haben darum geht es ihnen sind
Kampagnen gegen Klimaschutz das ist ihr
Motiv und ihr Antrieb das ist alles und
jetzt versuchen sie das was sie gemacht
haben in 16 Jahren jetzt mit unlauteren
Mitteln vorzusetzen ich sage Ihnen sie
können das machen sie können weiter
versuchen ihre fossilen klimaanleugner
Agenten voranzutreiben es wird nichts
ändern sie haben Deutschland in
Abhängigkeit von Diktatoren von
Autokraten getrieben von Wladimir Putin
getrieben und genau das beenden wir
jetzt ich verstehe dass ihnen das weh
tut ich verstehe dass sie damit nicht
klar kommen und ich sage Ihnen trotzdem
die Zeit fossiler C du Lobbyisten in
Staatsämtern ist abgelaufen ich kann ihn
raten gewinnen sie sich dran
wir können froh sein dass Robert Habeck
und Patrick reichen in Verantwortung
gewesen sind und das Land gut durch den
letzten Winter gebracht haben was haben
Sie von Blackouts geredet was haben sie
beschworen am Ende ist eins rausgekommen
jede Wohnung war warm zu jedem Zeitpunkt
und die Wirtschaft steht heute dank der
Arbeit der beiden trotz massiver Krisen
stabil da Fachleute die Patrick reichen
im Ministerium gehabt zu haben war in
dieser Zeit so zentral wissen Sie warum
weil sie uns einen Scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen haben unter CDU und CSU
fand ein Ausverkauf Deutschlands ohne
Beispiel statt sie haben zentrale
Infrastruktur an Russland verscherbelt
im Jahr 2015 haben sie zugelassen dass
unser größter Gasspeicher in Reden von
Gasprom gekauft wurde als Robert Habeck
und Patrick reichen 2021 ins
Wirtschaftsministerium gekommen sind da
weiß wenige Monate vor Kriegsbeginn und
die Speicher waren erschreckend leer
ihre Verantwortung ebenfalls 2015 ging
die Unternehmen PCK Schwedt bayern-oil
und Miro Karlsruhe mehrheitlich anders
russische Unternehmen Rosneft unter
ihrer Kanzlerschaft unter ihre
Verantwortung und noch was passierte
2015 der Gesellschaftervertrag zur
Umsetzung von nordstream 2 wurde
unterschrieben halb Europa hat gewarnt
wir Grüne haben immer wieder gewarnt sie
haben das gemacht und die Abhängigkeit
immer weiter zementiert über Jahre haben
sie den Ausverkauf Deutschlands
vorangetrieben das ist das was zum
Himmel stinkt das ist das was man sich
anschauen muss und genau das ist das was
dringend untersucht werden muss
aber der Ausverkauf auf der einen Seite
da hat ihnen nicht gereicht in dieser
Zeit zur selben Zeit haben CDU und CSU
den Ausbau heimischer sicherer
erneuerbarer Energien blockiert und
dabei hunderttausende Jobs zerstört sie
wissen sie wissen genau was die
altmaierdelle ist mindestens 60.000 Jobs
in der Windbranche haben sie zerstört es
ihre Verantwortung Deutschland hatte mal
eine florierende Solarindustrie das war
mal diesmal haben sie wieder
verscherbelt aber nach China wir hatten
mal 130.000 Jobs in der Solarbranche
sind noch 30.000 übrig ihre
Verantwortung weil sie eine Politik für
die fossilen autokarten gemacht haben
und eben nicht für die Energiewende
nicht das was Deutschland Zukunft
gebracht hätte und den Scherben haben
dass sie den sie damit angerichtet haben
den müssen wir jetzt aufräumen
und all das sollte niemanden wundern
anstatt erneuerbare auszubauen hat Peter
Altmaier sich in seiner Zeit lieber mit
klimaleugnern windkraftgegnern in seinem
privaten Garten in Rehlingen-Siersburg
getroffen bis 2021 ging die Klima
Leugner Lobby vernunftkraft im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ein und aus
das ist Wahnsinn und wie systematisch
sie einerseits deutsche Infrastruktur an
Autokraten verscherbelt haben und
andererseits die sicheren Erneuerbaren
blockiert haben zeigt auch einen Blick
auf das sogenannte Bermudadreieck Thomas
Bareiß Carsten Linnemann und Joachim
Pfeiffer haben über Jahre jeglichen
Klimaschutz blockiert und ausgehebelt
und da schließt sich da schließt sich
übrigens ein Kreis verschließt sich ein
Kreis und den sollte man sich einmal vor
Augen führen Joachim Pfeiffer hat
Klimaschutz gerne als
Ersatzreligion bezeichnet wissen Sie
wissen sie an wen mich das erinnert
Ersatzreligion sei Klimaschutz an Sie
Herr Merz an sie erinnert mich das sie
haben vor einigen Tagen wiederholt das
Klimaschutz überbewertet sein stellen
sich genauso genau in diese genau in
diese Linie sie haben nichts gelernt sie
sind weiterhin eine Partei die tief im
fossilen Summen verstrickt ist das ist
das das verspreche ich Ihnen dass wir
aufarbeiten werden und dann werden wir
sehen dass wir am Ende an der Stelle
landen wo klar ist die fossile Zeit für
CSU-Leute für CDU Leute ist vorbei die
Zukunft ist erneuerbar danke Ihnen
Andreas
die Grünen nächster Redner in dieser
aktuellen Stunde Klaus Ernst erste
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Klimaschutz also mit dem
Wirtschaftsausschuss der Ausschuss in
dem heute auch Minister Robert Habeck
sich den Fragen der Ausschuss Mitglieder
gestellt hat
und Herren
jetzt möchte ich erstmal nochmal auf dem
Kollegen Andritz eingehen ja da gab es
natürlich bei der CDU viel Punkte die
man kritisieren konnte da gab es die
Masken für die weiße kuck noch da gab es
ja eine Affäre nach der anderen aber
wollen Sie wirklich ihre eigenen
Missstände damit rechtfertigen dass es
bei ihnen auch das ist bei denen auch
Affären gab das heute für nicht korrekt
es ist schon richtig wer im Glashaus
sitzt soll ich mit Steinen werfen aber
wenn alle im Glashaus sitzen wir auf
keinen mehr mit Steinen und sowas geht
einfach durch was ihr macht und das ist
nicht in Ordnung das ist nicht in
Ordnung ich habe den Eindruck den wir
haben andere schwer es lieber gewesen
das war alles im Sumpf geblieben kein
Herz gemerkt er wird es dann besser
gewesen
inzwischen ist doch inzwischen ist doch
zugegeben von dem zuständig Minister von
ergreifen das ist alles nicht in Ordnung
war wenn man das nicht mehr ansprechen
darf weil man selber vielleicht in der
Vergangenheit auch nicht ganz sauber war
dann ist es sie können gerne
Zwischenfrage stellen wenn sie so gern
rum brüllen machen aber bitte das ist
doch ein Zustand dann würden solche
Punkte nicht mehr aufgedeckt und das
finde ich nicht in Ordnung das gilt auch
für sie von SPD sie haben die selbe
Richtung argumentiert weil die die
schlimme Finger waren zum dürfen wir
auch schlimme Finger sein und das ist
ein Punkt der ist nicht akzeptabel meine
Damen und mit aller Klarheit so und
jetzt zu dem eigentlichen Punkt
das ist Transparenz die die Koalition
ist doch angetreten mit dem Punkt bei
dieser nach dieser Wahl in dem
Koalitionsvertrag mehr Transparenz wir
hoffen mehr Beteiligung des Trank ist
Parlaments jetzt wollten wir heute eine
Öffentlichkeit herstellen bei den zwei
Ausschusssitzungen das ist das ist
zumindest bei uns im klimaausschuss
abgestimmt worden die Koalition hat
dann hat selbst dann hat selbst der
Harbeck noch mal als wir die Anhörung
hatte gemeinsame Anhörung gemeinsame
Ausschusssitzung von Klimaschutz
Wirtschaftsausschuss selbst dann hat er
habe gesagt er hat gar nichts dagegen
dass man sich öffentlich macht ja was
ist dann passiert dann hat der Ausschuss
Gewitter genauso abgestimmt wie vorher
sie sind nicht für mehr Transparenz
sondern sie wollten den Punkt
verschleiern und deshalb ist es gut dass
wir das nochmal auf der Tagesordnung hat
meine Damen und das sind alle Klarheit
so
aber zu dem was eigentlich der Vorgang
selber den haben wir jetzt rauf und
runter diskutiert wir wissen was ist
eigentlich aus meiner Sicht das ist ja
auch heute zur Sprache gekommen das ist
ein Verstoß gegen Compliance Regelungen
und eigentlich müsste das natürlich auch
beamtenrechtliche Konsequenzen haben sie
haben gesagt sie prüfen das ihr prüftes
dann bin ich aber gespannt auf das
Ergebnis der Prüfung denn das ist ja
kein das ist ja kein super
kartell-vorgang aber das muss ja erstmal
selber wissen wie lange es noch in der
Öffentlichkeit halten wollt viel
schlimmer ist allerdings folgende
Umstand ist entsteht ja der Eindruck
dass eine Partei die sich im Klimaschutz
zu Recht verschrieben hat also so
richtig verstehen dass diese Partei den
Klimaschutz jetzt nicht durchsetzt in
einem breiten gesellschaftlichen Konsens
mit mit möglichst vielen Fachleuten
wirklich vielen die man vielleicht noch
überzeugen muss beim Klimaschutz
mitzumachen sondern der Eindruck
entstehbar macht das anders man versetzt
sozusagen das wichtigste Ministerium in
dem Zusammenhang soll mit mit Freunden
wobei es jetzt unerheblich ist ob Freund
ob Trauzeuge oder Blutsbruder das ist
man jetzt in dem Zusammenhang wurscht
aber aber das wenn der Eindruck wenn der
Eindruck draußen entsteht dass das des
zuständige Ministerium sozusagen nur
noch mit den eigenen Leuten besetzen und
damit auch andere Meinungen im eigenen
Ministerium gibt es ja auch Fachleute
sind eine bloß grüne da drin sind
sondern da gibt's auch Fachleute und ich
habe das jetzt gar nicht so gemein wie
ihr das wieder aber man kann so
interpretieren einverstanden aber dann
wenn es so ist dann musst du doch die
mitreden lassen da muss doch die
Gesellschaft mitnehmen bei diesem
Klimaschutz und wenn draußen der
Eindruck entsteht das ist eine im grub
diese da da muss man erst mit der
zugehören möglicherweise 20 Jahre schon
äh was war sie gegen Atomkraft
demonstriert oder wo sie auch haben zu
sagen aber die Voraussetzung dazu ist
dass wir in einem Ministerium kommt dann
ist es nicht in Ordnung und der
Klimaschutz scheitert weil er nicht
breit auf gestellt ist das ist das
eigentliche Problem an ihrer Politik
meine Damen und Herren
so
und vielleicht auch noch was
das was sie da machen das erinnert mich
ein bisschen so an am Pferderennen
die haben links und rechts die
Scheuklappen und dann rennen sie in eine
Richtung ne und da wird aber immer
geguckt was ist rechts und links von der
Klappe und wenn man Klimapolitik
betreibt Busse vielleicht auch gucken
was hat es für Auswirkungen auf andere
Politikbereiche und ich habe den
Eindruck wenn man eben die Leute nur mit
so einer Richtung besetzt im Ministerium
dann bekommen die anderen Punkte zu kurz
und es ist genau das Problem z.B beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz das haben wir
genau den Punkt dass sie nur in eine
Richtung kommt es eigentlich leider noch
bezahlen was kostet es eigentlich was
sind die Konsequenzen des über das tun
dann machen sie ja Grenze von 80 Jahren
okay der 79 Jahre alt bitte
solche Dinge gehen nicht und deshalb
korrigieren Sie diese grundsätzliche
Politik der Besetzung ihrer stellen
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Olaf in der Weg
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
leider müssen wir nach der aktuellen
Stunde vor zwei Wochen heute erneut über
das leidige Thema der Personalpolitik im
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz sprechen letzte
Sitzungswoche habe ich zu Beginn meiner
Rede von notwendigen Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unsere in
unsere Institutionen gesprochen leider
müssen wir feststellen die letzten 14
Tage haben hier nicht gerade für
Entspannung gesorgt was wir jetzt
brauchen ist wie schon vor zwei Wochen
gefordert vollste Transparenz denn
keiner hier im Saal kann ernsthaft an
Interesse daran haben dass durch solche
Vorgänge das Vertrauen in Politik
insgesamt beschädigt wird das ist unsere
Verantwortung hier im Parlament aber
natürlich auch in der Exekutive also dem
Ministerien und anderen Behörden oder
staatlichen Institutionen diese
Transparenz hat das Ministerium heute in
der gemeinsamen Sitzung vom Ausschuss
für Wirtschaft und Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie zugesagt daran
werden wir sie müssen müssen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor zwei Wochen war es ein
Geschmäckle wie es meinen SPD-Kollege
Hüpfer letzte Woche ausdrückte heute
sind wir darüber leider hinaus durch die
sogenannte trauzeugenaffäre kam ein
neues Kapitel hinzu nachdem man sich
sicherlich ohne weiteres zur
Tagesordnung übergehen kann als
regierungstragende Fraktion erwarten wir
dass im Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz alle kritischen
Vorgängen nun rund um aufgeklärt und
mögliche Verstrickungen offengelegt
werden das ohnehin gerade verlorene
Vertrauen muss nun durch volle
Transparenz zurückgelangt werden denn
das sind wir den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
in unserem Land schuldig dazu gehört
selbstverständlich
dass die neue Besetzung der Deutschen
Energieagentur Dehner diese muss
nachvollziehbar transparent und fair
durchgeführt werden daran darf es kein
Zweifel geben wir dürfen die Integrität
vom Ministerien und
bundeseigeninstitutionen weder in Frage
stellen noch Anlass zu Kritik durch
fragwürdige Entscheidungen geben dass
sie von der Union sich allerdings hier
als Hüter der Transparenz stilisieren
das ist ihr gutes Recht als Opposition
auch den Finger in die Wunde zu legen
auch geschenkt aber machen Sie sich doch
nicht lächerlich wenn Sie hier über
Vorteilnahme und Compliance reden das
kauft ihnen wirklich keiner ab neben
allen neben allen wichtigen Fragen der
Transparenz führt dieses
selbstverursachte Theater so muss man es
ja leider nennen zu einem erheblichen
Vertrauensverlust und
glaubwürdigkeitsproblemen zuträglich
zuträglich für unser gemeinsames Ziel
Klimaschutz sind diese Vorgänge ganz
sicher nicht
zumal zumal das Parlament und die
Regierung in der Tat bessere Dinge zu
tun hätten als ich ihn regelmäßigen
Abständen mit der Personalpolitik eines
Ministeriums auseinanderzusetzen jetzt
ja wenn Personalien über Wochen eine
größere Rolle spielen als Inhalte und
Politik dann läuft liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in der Tat etwas falsch wir
haben große Herausforderungen gerade im
Wirtschaftsklima und energieressor wir
können es uns schlichtweg nicht erlauben
uns wochenlang mit selten mit uns selbst
zu beschäftigen dafür sind die Themen
definitiv zu wichtig und das ist auch
dem Parlament und der Regierung nicht
angemessen ich hoffe also dass und das
ist ein Appell an alle Beteiligten dass
wir schnellstmöglich wieder über Themen
sprechen anstatt über Personalien in
diesem Sinne kann ich meine eingängliche
Forderung nur noch einmal wiederholen
was die Menschen fordern und zwar zu
Recht ist lückenlose Aufklärung und
Transparenz auch daran werden Sie lieber
Herr Minister Habig gemessen
das gilt ebenfalls für die Information
die an die Koalitionspartner schnell
weitergereicht werden sollten dann
können wir die Zeit der aktuellen
Stunden in Zukunft auch wieder für
inhaltsvolle Diskussionen verwenden
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege so weit Olaf in
der Beek das Präsidium hat gewechselt
Wolfgang Kubicki leitet nun hier diese
Sitzung und ruft auf Andreas Lenz aus
der Unionsfraktion die Unionsfraktion
hat dieser aktuelle Stunde ja beantragt
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute über das System gleichen im bmwk
und viele auch aus den Rhein der Ampel
sprechen ja von Transparenz wir waren
gerade im Ausschuss und haben beantragt
dass der Ausschuss öffentlich tagt der
Minister Habeck hat es auch befürwortet
aber die Ampel kennt der Weg hat dagegen
gestimmt das ist das Gegenteil von
Transparenz was gerade passiert ist
der grüne Pilz hat System und
durchdringt das Ministerium dass
spiegelt sich auch und gerade in der
Personalpolitik wieder und jetzt heißt
es oft es wurde sich ja entschuldigt ich
zitiere Herrn reichen der sagt im
Verfahren der Findungskommission habe
ich leider nicht richtig aufgepasst zu
die Stellungnahme so eine Entschuldigung
ist keine Entschuldigung das heißt
eigentlich nur er entschuldigt sich
dafür dass er nicht geschickt genug dass
er sich nicht geschubst genug angestellt
hast nicht aufgepasst dass er seinen
Trauzeugen für einen spitzen Job
vorgeschlagen hat wo er sich selbst in
die Findungskommission gesetzt hat und
den er im Auswahlgespräch sogar Sitze es
ist doch nur eine Entschuldigung dass er
sich erwischen lassen hat das ist wieder
glaubhaft noch ernst gemeint meine Damen
und Herren
die Affäre greifen ist das Problem habe
ich und zeigt auch die mangelnde Führung
innerhalb der Bundesregierung durch
Bundeskanzler Scholz wir fordern sie auf
ziehen Sie die entsprechenden
Konsequenzen meine Damen und Herren
und neuerdings stilisieren sich die
Grünen auch hier zum Opfer und beklagen
sich über die bösen möge Medien die
Opposition auch die Opposition innerhalb
der Ampel das mag vielleicht ein
Stilmittel sein aber das ist doch kein
Stil meine Damen und Herren auch für die
Grünen muskelten was für alle gibt ich
wurde ja jetzt ein paar mal gefragt
woher ich wusste dass Schäfer gleich ins
Trauzeuge ist ich frage mich viel ich
frage mich viel mehr wie konnten das so
viele wissen und so lange nicht sagen
meine Damen und Herren
das das erinnert doch an
schweigekartelle in der letzten
Aktuellen Stunde sagten Vertreter der
Ampel noch es gäbe es gäbe nichts Neues
mittlerweile diesen hier noch jeden Tag
etwas Neues in der Zeitung über
Auftragsvergaben über Vätern Wirtschaft
über Finanzierungsstrukturen
also von BMU und bmwk an das
Öko-Institut ist ein Skandal hier werden
Aufträge gegeneinander zugestanzt und es
gibt doch es gibt noch mehr und wir
werden auch noch mehr zu Tage fördern
meine Damen und Herren
aber es geht doch auch es geht doch auch
um Konformismus und es geht auch um gut
cnaht und die tun keiner Organisation
gut das wird aber auch durch diese
Personalpolitik entsprechend befördert
wird unterdrückt die Theorie wird zur
Praxis erklärt vermurkste Gesetze wieder
heizungshammer der die heizungsverbote
regelt haben ihren Ursprung eben genau
in diesen Instituten eine agora Studie
aus dem November 2022 hat den Titel
Durchbruch für die Wärmepumpe keine
schlechte Technologie aber eben nicht
die einzige Technologie Gesetzgebung
verschwimmt mit konzeptionellen
Überlegungen und wer schreibt
mittlerweile den eigentlich die Gesetze
im bmwk diese Frage stellt sich doch aus
stimmt stimmt es dass die Gesetze aus
der Abteilung zwei und drei von Akkorde
gegen gecheckt werden es wurde neulich
es wurde neulich argumentiert es gäbe es
gäbe nicht zu viel Experten im
Energiebereich und reichen sei eben
einer dieser Experten wenn ich mir wenn
ich mir die vermurkse gasumlage anschaue
wenn ich mir die heizungsverbote
anschaue dann denke ich ich bin mir da
nicht so sicher ob hier nur Experten an
Werk sind im BMW kam meine Damen und
Herren
bzw wie kommt das Wort Experte dann eine
ganz andere Bedeutung an bekannter
Heizungsbauer von mir bezweifelt auch ob
es hier tatsächlich Experten sind die am
Werke sind und Sie merken doch sie
spüren doch die Verunsicherung die sie
mit ihrer murksgesetzgebung entsprechend
in der Bevölkerung anrichten und wir
fordern sie auf auch hier entsprechend
sich zu bewegen und eben den
Praxis-Check zu machen und eben auch
praktikable Gesetze aus ihrem Haus
vorzulegen Klimaschutz geht nur mit den
Leuten und nicht gegen die Menschen
dafür stehen wir sie stehen für Verbote
und Vätern Wirtschaft wir werden weiter
aufklären herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun als
nächster Markus hümpfer das Wort auch er
sitzt im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und
Energie wie hier schon einige Vorredner
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
haben uns in der letzten Sitzungswoche
über dieses Thema unterhalten wir haben
uns heute Mittag im Ausschuss über
dieses Thema unterhalten und jetzt
unterhalten wir uns schon wieder darüber
bei aller Empörung die ich in Teilen
auch nachvollziehen kann was sie von
sich gegeben haben ist plumber Wahlkampf
sie versuchen hier mit allen Mitteln die
Ampel schlecht zu machen sie schrecken
vor nichts zurück sie schrecken von
nichts zurück herr Lenz sie nutzt seine
Sprache die einfach nur widerlich ist
schämen sollten Sie sich
mit Transparenz kennen sich ihre
Fraktion ja aus ich habe Ihnen schon mal
gesagt wer im Glashaus sitzt soll nicht
mit Steinen werfen Gisela mandarela
Abgeordnete ihre Fraktion in der letzten
Wahlperiode hat die Ehefrau eines
hochrangigen rüstungslobbyisten
beschäftigt so weit so gut wenn sie
nicht zufällig auch Mitglied im
Verteidigungsausschuss gewesen wäre die
berateraffären unter Ursula von der
Leyen als Verteidigungsministerin
Philipp Amthor die masken-deals die
PKW-Maut ihr Ministerpräsident Daniel
Günther befördert in einer Tour seinen
kleinen Bruder Tobias Rischer in
Schleswig-Holstein vom Pressesprecher
zum Abteilungsleiter und seit März zum
vize-direktor des Landtags was man nicht
alles für die Familie tut und sie wollen
uns hier was über familiäre
Verpflichtungen erzählen dass ich nicht
lacht den dicksten Filz in der deutschen
Politik finden wir in ihrer Fraktion
worum geht es eigentlich genau und was
hat sich seit der letzten Sitzungswoche
geändert das letzte Mal ging es um
familiäre und finanzielle Beziehungen
zwischen dem Bundesministerium für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und dem
unabhängigen Ökoinstitut dazu habe ich
schon alles gesagt klären wir also
lieber die Frage was sich seitdem
geändert hat die deutsche Energieagentur
hat den Chefposten neu zu vergeben und
wie das so üblich ist bildet sich eine
Findungskommission die findet kompetente
Bewerberinnen und Bewerber und schlägt
dem aussichtsrat jemanden für den Posten
vor in dieser Findungskommission war
Patrick reichen vertreten was auch nicht
unüblich ist als Staatssekretär beworben
haben sich elf Personen darunter auch
Michael Schäfer ein guter Freund von
Patrick reichen der auch sein Trauzeuge
war und nach dem Willen der
Findungskommission und das Aufsichtsrats
sollte es dann auch Schäfer werden und
jetzt muss man trennen
es geht nämlich nicht um die fachliche
Kompetenz von Michael Schäfer es geht
einzig um und allein um die enge
persönliche Bindung zwischen Schäfer und
gleichen und um ein Problem Patrick
reichen hat die persönlichen Beziehungen
erst vier Wochen später offengelegt das
hat nicht nur ein Geschmäckle das hat
ein bitteren Nachgeschmack das ist
unprofessionell das muss man so sagen
dabei ist die Maus kein Faden ab das war
ein Fehler und zu Fehlern muss man auch
stehen
jetzt muss man jetzt muss man wissen ich
komme aus der freien Wirtschaft und in
der freien Wirtschaft ist eine gute
Fehlerkultur das A und O von
erfolgreichen Unternehmen und deshalb
bin ich froh dass es diese Fehlerkultur
offensichtlich auch im Ministerium gibt
man hat gelernt das Verfahren wird
komplett neu aufgesetzt es wird
transparenter die Findungskommission
größer und das ist auch gut so geht
deshalb Vertrauen in den Klimaschutz
verloren passend zum Titel ihrer
aktuellen Stunde nein das glaube ich
nicht wir sehen nämlich jedes Jahr dass
ich extreme Wetterereignisse mehren wir
sehen das Klimaschutz notwendig ist
aber eine Frage bleibt ist die
Personalpolitik wirklich so besonders
und da muss man sagen nein das ist sie
nicht schon immer haben sich Ministerin
um Minister mit loyalen Leuten umgeben
das hat die Union so gemacht dass haben
die Grünen so gemacht das ist auch
logisch in den USA wird bei einem
Regierungswechsel sogar die gesamte
Belegschaft einmal ausgetauscht das geht
bei uns zum Glück nicht und das ist auch
wichtig was lernen wir jetzt daraus
Transparenz ist wichtig und Kontrolle
auch beides ist gegeben und deshalb und
deshalb ist ihre aktuelle Stunde wie
schon die letzte aktuelle Stunde der
afd-fraktion eine Stunde die wir auch
hätten sinnvoller verbringen können in
diesem Haus vielen Dank
vielen Dank
der Kollege nächster Redner ist der
Kollege Felix
herr Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde
das spannend wenn die CDU die Wahl hat
zwischen dem Demokraten Bodo Ramelow
oder mit den AFD Stimmen gemeinsam
Thomas Kemmerich zum Ministerpräsidenten
zu wählen dann steht die Brandmauer nach
links aber wenn wir nordstream-fan Klaus
Ernst nachdem man gestern Abend mit Tino
krupala Gerhard Schröder und Egon Krenz
in der russischen Botschaft mit krimsek
angestoßen hat hier redet dann können
sie sich kaum halten auf ihren Plätzen
ich finde das erbärmlich
meine Damen und Herren
Demokratie
demokratie lebt von Integrität und
transparenzdemokratie lebt vom harten
Austausch in der Sache vom Respekt vor
dem persönlichen gegenüber und
demokratie lebt von Mars und Mitte in
der politischen Auseinandersetzung und
meine Damen und Herren von Union dieses
Maß haben Sie in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen und auch heute vollkommen
verloren vollkommen verloren haben sie
dieses Maß
wenn
wenn die Person die wie keine andere in
der Bundesregierung nach dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
Verantwortung dafür getragen hat unsere
Volkswirtschaft und unsere Gesellschaft
vor dem größten Kollaps zu bewahren den
die Energiekrise ausgelöst hat für die
sie Verantwortung tragen durch ihre
Politik der 16 Jahre und sie diesen
Menschen vergleichen und in eine Ecke
stellen wie der Dreieck und dies gemacht
haben mit kriminellen dann ist das dem
Hause dem Niveau dieses Hauses nicht
angemessen und ich finde es sollte auch
nicht ihr Niveau sein als größte
Opposition
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe
mich
ich habe mich im Vorhinein gefragt und
ich hatte Zweifel ob ich hier mal die
These ansprechen kann das ist vielleicht
kein Zufall ist dass eine seit 16
Monaten bekannte verwandtschaftliche
Verbindungen zwischen einem
parlamentarischen und einem beamteten
Staatssekretär ausgerechnet dann in
dieser Form skandalisiert wird wenn wir
über das Gebäude Energiegesetz sprechen
wenn wir über die Zukunft von
gasinfrastruktur sprechen wenn wir über
die Zukunft fossiler Geschäftsmodelle
sprechen ich dachte wenn ich das sage
dann wird man hier Verschwörungstheorie
angedichtet Herr Chaya sie haben vier
Minuten selbst getan es geht ihnen ganz
offensichtlich hier nicht um Integrität
es geht ihnen um Interesse es geht ihnen
um politisches Interesse diese
Bundesregierung diesen Minister und
einen starken Mann in seinem Ministerium
zu diffamieren zu der legitimieren zu
diskreditieren es geht ihnen um die
Interessen der fossilen Wirtschaft die
sie vertreten und vertreten haben über
Jahrzehnte und es geht ihnen nicht um
Compliance es geht ihnen nicht um
Aufklärung denn ansonsten würden sie
hier anders agieren
wir hatten zweieinhalb Stunden heute
eine gemeinsame Sitzung des Wirtschafts-
und des Energie- und klimaausschusses
zweieinhalb Stunden in dem Herr
Bundesminister Robert Habeck Herr
Staatssekretär Patrick reichen
Parlamentarische Staatssekretär Stefan
Wenzel und die Frau Staatssekretärin
Anja haiduck jede Frage aus der
Opposition aus der Koalition heraus
intensiv beantwortet haben jede
Nachfrage beantwortet haben alle Fragen
sind geantwortet alle Fakten liegen auf
dem Tisch am Ende bleibt genau eine
Sache über und hier geht es um den
vierten Teil von Demokratie
demokratie braucht Fehler Kultur und ja
es fällt mir überhaupt nicht schwer zu
sagen dass hier ein Fehler passiert ist
und sie haben mir vorhin aufgehorcht als
es der Kollege Sebastian Roloff
angesprochen habe als er gesagt hat da
ist ein Fehler passiert
das kennen sie gar nicht das kennen sie
gar nicht in der Union dass man einen
Fehler akzeptieren dass man dazu stehen
dass man sich für einen Fehler
entschuldigen darum Entschuldigung
bitten kann dass man aus einem Fehler
Konsequenzen zieht dass man daraus lernt
und dass man daraus besser wird für die
Zukunft das bmwk das Bundesministerium
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz hat heute
im Ausschuss eindrucksvoll bewiesen dass
es diese Fehlerkultur beherrscht und es
hat auch aus so eindrucksvoll bewiesen
es hat eindrucksvoll bewiesen dass am
Ende hinter all dem Geflecht hinter all
den Schaubildern die sie malen hinter
allem wer mal mit wem in der Straßenbahn
saß auf dem Weg zum gleichen Club dass
da am Ende eine Sache übrig bleibt die
ist aufgeklärt worden daraus werden
Konsequenzen gezogen das ist Demokratie
vielen Dank
felix war das hat ja auch angekündigt es
werden Konsequenzen gezogen die ersten
sind ja auch schon gezogen worden
und nun ist der nächste Redner ohne
Applaus weil er fraktionslos ist nachdem
er bei der AFD Fraktion war robertal
spricht als nächstes
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
der Sumpf
ist grenzenlos
er fängt bei Habeck an gleichen Clan
das sind die
amigoaffären die jetzt beim grünen
Ministerium sind die vorher in Bayern
Mal waren
amigo ist überall in den Ministerien man
sieht nämlich dass die Berufung auch
beim Justizministerium sich Leute
eingestellt werden
ohne ohne Bewerbung miteinander
abzuwählen der Sumpf ist tief drin und
wissen sie das ist das was sich jetzt
langsam ändert immer mehr Menschen in
unserem Land begreifen wie tief dieser
Sumpf ist und das ist eine grundlegende
Korrektur in der Politik bedarf
sie haben einen Bundeskanzler der kein
Rückgrat hat um einen Herrn Harbeck klar
zu sagen es geht so nicht und diese
Väter des Wirtschaft muss beendet werden
dieses Rückgrat bringt ja nicht auf
warum weil er mitfährt
selbst genug zu tun hat und demnächst in
dem Untersuchungsausschuss steht
wir haben eine EU-Spitze
der Spitzenkraft die Frau von der Leyen
ist die mehrere Milliarden Euro fürs hat
versumpfen lassen buchstäblich für
Impfstoffe die kein Mensch gebraucht hat
die jetzt verloren sind das kriegen die
Leute doch mit wir haben eine grüne
Partei bei der sich jeder fragt schauen
Sie mal ins manager magazin ich habe den
Artikel hier ich kann das zeitgrün
nichts dazu sagen im Einzelnen lesen Sie
mal oder sowas da ist eine Grafik drin
wo die ganzen Verästelungen ihrer grünen
Partei zur Großfinanz und zu der
multimilliardären in den USA aufgelistet
sind denn davor werden sie gesteuert die
grüne Parteien
aus den USA haben unsere Wirtschaft zu
zerstören das sehen wir doch zum Schluss
kommen
räumen
Robert Falle vermutet hier auch Einfluss
von außen auf die Regierung
der Kollege ich hätte dafür einen
ordnungssuche für die Bemerkung Alter
mit deinem Gelaber ist des Hauses
unwürdig und das bin ich wirklich ernst
zu nehmen
so als nächster Redner hat der Kollege
Rainer Thun hier gab es noch einen
Zwischenruf den wir aber nicht
wiederholen wollen sondern jetzt geht es
hier weiter mit der Rednerliste rein hat
Huben für die FDP hat das Wort
meine Damen und Herren herr Präsident
meine Partei hat sich mal in sehr
dunklen Tagen ein Leitbildprozess
unterworfen
und hat sich versprochen wechselseitig
nicht auf bestimmte Reflexe zu reagieren
wir wissen im politischen Geschäft
das nicht unbedingt wenn zwei das
gleiche tun ist dasselbe ist und
natürlich
gibt es Tendenzen im Haus die sich in
Anführungszeichen freuen
dass jetzt auch mal die Grünen eine
solche Debatte haben
aber meine Damen und Herren ich bin mir
nicht sicher wenn wir das so pflegen wie
es hier zum Teil gepflegt worden ist ob
wir wirklich das Vertrauen in die
Politik insgesamt erhöhen wir haben uns
heute
wir haben uns heute eigentlich den
ganzen Tag um die kaiserreichen
gekümmert
und ich frage Sie
haben wir nicht andere Probleme
ergreifen
Herr Graichen hat
persönlich seinen Fehler eingestanden
das ist menschlich Frau Kollegin
Klöckner ich glaube sie sind in der CDU
das ist menschlich korrekt dass er
gleich in das getan hat ob das politisch
und ob das beamtenrechtlich reicht dass
er in der Position bleibt in der er ist
die Frage wird geklärt und ist zu klären
aber dann meine Damen und Herren möchte
ich doch darauf hinweisen dass manche
dass manche ihre Reden vielleicht noch
mal umschreiben wenn Sie einen
bestimmten Veranstaltungen teilnehmen
also
da ist die Frage der Transparenz
angesprochen worden der Kollege jung hat
eigentlich im Wort telegram nach der
Sitzung berichtet was besprochen worden
ist und sich dann hier hinzustellen und
sich zu empören dass keine Transparenz
gegeben ist also wenn man es nicht ernst
nimmt mit nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen
Kollegium dann darf man sich auch nicht
wundern dass es zu einer gewissen
Kritik kommt also sie haben doch den
Inhalt der Sitzung medial transportiert
und sie wissen ganz genau dass natürlich
in nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen die aus
dem üblich sind ganz anders
Informationen ausgetauscht werden
zwischen den Ministerien und der
entsprechenden politischen Seite im
Gegensatz dazu wenn halt Öffentlichkeit
hergestellt ist deswegen ist es eine
meiner Meinung nach sehr unehrliche
Debatte
und
dann sollten wir doch zum Punkt kommen
und das ist in der Sitzung eben ja klar
geworden
deswegen ist Helium hat angekündigt
beamtenrechtliche Fragen gegen eine
überherren reichen zu prüfen
und da hat der Minister auch zugestimmt
hat gesagt ich sage jetzt zu dem Thema
gar nichts mehr ich warte jetzt formal
ab was passiert und das ist auch meiner
Meinung nach richtig so meine Damen und
Herren und dann brauchen wir auch keine
weitere Aufregung an diesem Punkt und
dann ist natürlich auch die Frage
aufgekommen wie gehen wir mit der Dehner
um und wie gehen wir mit entsprechenden
Problemen die durch die Vertrags
Abschließung eben entstanden sind wie
gehen wir damit um
und auch da hat es klare Signale aus dem
Ministerium gegeben jeder der dabei war
kann es in seinen Fraktionen ja
berichten also da gibt es keine
Unklarheiten und
erlauben Sie mir noch eine Bemerkung die
mit der causer reichen gar nichts zu tun
hat
aber wie sich manche hier moralisch
erheben
die am Abend davor an einem Empfang der
russischen Botschaft teilnehmen Herr
Kollege Ernst bei aller Liebe wie kann
man da hingehen ich kann es wirklich
nicht verstehen
und deswegen empfehle ich
deswegen empfehle ich uns allen weniger
persönliche Häme ich weiß wovon ich
spreche bei der Partei aus der ich komme
und etwas mehr sachliche Debatte und
vernünftigen Umgang miteinander denn
wenn wir uns hier nur so miteinander
beschäftigen wie in den letzten 50
Minuten werden das die Bürger auch nicht
positiv begleiten vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege und damit
kommen wir hier zum letzten Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde auch wenn das
Thema natürlich noch weiter hier das
politische Berlin beschäftigen wird und
der letzte Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Kollege Huben sie waren ja in der
letzten Woche einer der ersten die den
Rückzug von Herrn Staatssekretär reichen
gefordert haben ich frage mich wo ist
ihr Mut geblieben es wäre doch so gut
gewesen wenn sich heute auch noch mal
getraut hätten
sehr geehrter Herr Minister Habeck ich
habe ihnen mal den fünf Punkteplan für
saubere und transparente Politik der
Grünen den sie noch als
Parteivorsitzender beschlossen haben
mitgebracht darin heißt es ich zitiere
schon dem Bösen Schein gekaufter und
beeinflusster Politik muss
entgegengewirkt werden der Einfluss von
organisierten Lobbyisten hat stark
zugenommen dennoch tut die
Bundesregierung nichts das stimmt nicht
nur der böse Schein der ist nämlich
schon längst überschritten sitzen heute
sogar die Lobbyisten sind mit ihren
Familien in der Regierung das ist der
Unterschied
und heute
und heute hätten sie für saubere und
transparente Politik einstehen können
aber als allererstes legen Sie die
beiden Ausschüsse zusammen um eine
getrennte Vernehmung um eine getrennte
Anhörung von Ihnen beiden von Herrn
reichen und von ihnen der Harbeck zu
verhindern um widersprüchliche Aussagen
zu verhindern so eine Sorge vor
getrennter Vernehmung kennt man
eigentlich nur im Strafprozess und da
hat man meistens etwas zu verbergen
und dass sie nun glauben dass man mit
vier Fragen pro Fraktionen dieses Netz
an Verquickung aufklären kann ist schon
fragwürdig über die Transparenz dass sie
nicht die Öffentlichkeit zulassen und
das gleich zwei Mal Ausscheiden
ausschließen das ist einfach Verhalten
das ist eine transparenzpartei wie sie
sich selber nennen Bündnis 90 die Grünen
nicht würdig sie predigen den Wein den
sie am Ende trinken aber sie hat nur das
Wasser getrunken das Wasser gepredigt
und den Wein getrunken kleiner
Versprecher aber es scheint die grüne
neue Devise zu sein und wenn man
wir trinken gerne noch ein Bier zusammen
Herr Kollege Limburg aber wenn man ihn
dann den Spiegel vorhält dann werden sie
so schnell dünnhäutig und dabei kann ich
verstehen dass wenn sie nach
kabinettsbeschlüssen ein heizungsverbot
im Ministerium feiern wo sich viele
Leute Sorgen machen dass sie Angst haben
ihr Haus zu verlieren und dann
gleichzeitig sich hier hinstellen wie
ein Kollege outletsch und von der Fossil
Lobby reden ich sage Ihnen das einzige
was Fossil ist das ist die
Personalpolitik die Sie in diesem
Ministerium machen und dann
und dann kommt noch und dann kommt noch
Herr banaschak an und erklärt ja hier
dass wir ja wieder die ganzen Schuldigen
werden ich sage Ihnen im ablenken von
Problemen da sind sie Weltmeister im
Lösen der Probleme sind sie kreisklasse
und bei ihnen gilt und bei ihnen gilt
das Motto verdecken vertuschen
verschleiern aufgeklärt und geheilt wie
sie ist Herr Minister nennen ist bislang
immer nur das was gerade so
scheibchenweise ans Tageslicht gekommen
ist sie machen dann rein Tisch wenn es
schon wieder not dazu ist gestern ziehen
Sie dann den Trauzeugen Schäfer aus dem
Verkehr heute kommt raus dass er eine
unterschriebenen Arbeitsvertrag hat und
finanzielle Forderungen gegenüber der
Dehner respektive dem Staat Bestehen der
Ablauf ist spannend der Aufsichtsrat
entscheidet Anfang April dass der
Trauzeuge Schäfer benannt werden soll
erst zwei Wochen später wird der
Arbeitsvertrag unterschrieben und nur
plötzlich fährt der Staatssekretär
reichen ein oder das ist ja mein
Trauzeuge und dann sagt er genau drei
Tage nach dieser Vertragsunterzeichnung
dass das Ganze dass das Ganze gar nicht
geht dass er mein traumzeuge dieser
Staatssekretär reichen der versorgt
nicht nur Familie und dann er sorgt
sogar für ein finanziellen Schaden und
das mit Vorsatz und deswegen werden wir
das weiter aufklären und dabei
und dabei sind noch lange nicht alle
Fragen beantwortet was machen die
dienstrechtlichen Konsequenzen gegen
Herrn reichen welchen Kontakt hatte Herr
reichen zur Personalagentur und wie
wurden aus sechs Kandidaten ein
Trauzeuge wie viele Stellen wurden in
den letzten Monaten eigentlich mit
Freunden und Bekannten von der Agora
Energiewende vom Ökoinstitut oder
anderen Organisationen besetzt und wie
kann eigentlich reichen versichern dass
er und seine Familienmitglieder nicht
möglicherweise sogar selbst von dieser
Politik profitieren ich sage Ihnen
Vorhang zu und alle Fragen offen damit
werden sie nicht durchkommen Herr
Minister es wird Zeit dass sie in
Staatssekretär entlassen und das
schneller als die Deutschen ihre Heizung
austauschen vielen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Kuban war das hier der
letzte Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
er hat es aber gesagt das wird hier
weiter
noch Thema sein und wir sehen jetzt auch
das der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck direkt zu ihm hingeht also dort
wirklich ein
Gesprächsbedarf besteht
das Mikrofon machen
wenn ich jetzt auch spannend
ich rufe auf jeden Tagesordnungspunkt 3
Beratung des Antrags
des Ministers der in der Aktuellen
Stunde nicht gesprochen hat hier zu den
Vorkommnissen um seinen Staatssekretär
Patrick reichen die Unionsfraktion hat
er schon gefordert dass es auch noch ein
Untersuchungsausschuss dazu geben soll
ob sie das nun weiter verfolgt werden
wir in den nächsten Wochen hier erfahren
hier ist doch jetzt einige Unruhe im
Parlament das bietet mir natürlich die
Gelegenheit aufs nächste Thema zu
schauen da wird es nämlich um die
einen Einsatz der Bundeswehr gehen
nämlich der Einsatz in Mali zehn Jahre
lang war die Bundeswehr in Mali aktiv
ist es immer noch jetzt soll sie bis im
Mai 2024 abziehen dieser Abzug soll
schon bald starten aber es dauert eben
eine Weile bis dann das ganze Material
z.B nach Deutschland gebracht wird
deswegen am ersten Juni soll der Abzug
der Rückzug beginnen denn man sieht sich
in Mali mit vielen Problemen
konfrontiert erst einmal hat man das
Ziel das Land zu stabilisieren dort für
Sicherheit zu sorgen nicht erreicht aber
auch die Militär runter behindert die
Bundeswehr bei ihren Einsätzen schon
seit längerer Zeit und ist